I feel so lucky to be here I thought my
comedy career was over to tell you the
truth because I emailed the Booker of a
comedy club recently and I said thanks
so much for having me I had a great time
I'd love to come back and do the show
again in the future but in my biggest
autocorrect mishap I did not say in I
said I'd love to do the show again I'm
the future it's a pretty bold statement
right I don't even think Kanye West has
said that so I thought about emailing
him back you know be like in the future
and then I realized the future would
never second-guess himself like that you
guys are probably thinking this guy is
pretty funny for a civil war re-enactor
truth be told I actually am a direct
descendant of ulysses s grant so I feel
like I've earned the right to look like
a douchebag he's my great great great
grandfather three greats and that's a
tremendous shadow to live under right he
was a decorated general who defeated the
south won the Civil War while I once
spent an entire game of laser tag
shooting the wrong team
and of course we all know he went on to
become president of the United States
face of the $50 bill and I have to see
his disapproving look every time I buy
drugs I have two adopted siblings I have
a sister who's 14 years older than me
she's half Indian and I have a brother
who's 18 years older than me he's half
Japanese so all of our photos together
it just looks like I'm sitting with a
team of doctors as they desperately try
to find me a cure but since there's so
much older than me I never got to break
the news to them that they were adopted
which that defeats the whole purpose of
having adopted siblings right like one
time we got in a fight I was like guess
what you're adopted they were like guess
what mom wanted us
[Music]
if my mom as I point goes the foreigners
my grandfather died when I was 8 years
old and my parents made a huge mistake
by telling me the truth which was that
he died in his sleep so for the next
year I was awake wide awake they be like
Doug it's bedtime what's that dead time
no thanks
sleep when I'm dead I'm dead if I sleep
it's gonna stay I make upon a coffee cue
up the Exorcist you guys knock
yourselves out though they'd be like all
right we'll see in the morning yeah
we'll see I think they shoulda lied to
me right I feel like it would have been
a great kid if they had just lied to me
like if I was in their shoes I would
have handled things a little differently
like if my kid was like how grandpa died
I would've been like well he was jumping
on the bed
after lying about brushing his teeth and
refusing to put his jammies on when he
fell and broke his neck on a GI Joey
left lying around
doctors say would have survived if only
he'd taken one more bite of broccoli
[Music]
now in our father's day I feel like I
should tell you a fun fact about my dad
my dad has one eye he lost his left eye
in a barbecuing accident that is the
correct response those Labor Day
cookouts are dangerous right he was
flipping burgers with a two-prong
barbecue fork and he caught it on the
grill sprang up pop him the I lost the
eye and I remember this happened before
I was born when I finally was able to
wrap my head around what happened I
asked my was like dad how'd you do that
were you drinking he was like nope sober
as a judge I was like you should
probably tell people you were drinking
you're just a bit of a butterfingers at
least if he was drinking he'd have the
best story at the AAA meeting right just
walk in there and be like well I think I
finally hit rock bottom he could never
get away with saying typical dad stuff
you know like hey knock it off I got
eyes in the back of my head it's like
really maybe she left the front of your
head borrow one
it's just so sad because it all could
have been avoided if he had just used a
spatula but as he likes to say
hindsight's
you